you're [ __ ] crazy so my here he's got
130 wants to say one person at a time
cats and dogs I mean this is it this is
this is the conversation we need to have
how have we not have this conversation
let's have it
I line with kitty cats and I align with
doggy dogs I am 100% for dogs 110
percent for cats my allegiance is with
dogs my allegiance is to cats team cat
because [ __ ] duh team dog because I
don't even have to argue about this we
have another little debate Oh what do I
even again dogs are man's best friend
loyalty humor utility they also have
this these multitude of ways that they
can serve us and enrich our lives cats
don't sniff out bombs cats aren't first
responders to 911 cats aren't guys gonna
bring in 911 blind people who use dogs
to see how old people can use service
dogs are a thing I've never heard of a
service cat and if I did that person's a
dumbass
I had a burglar once in my house my dog
barked the [ __ ] out of it I can't we'll
just let a stranger come in and just
take a [ __ ] you know else like is a
great utility is like a car the car can
like drive you from place to place it
could be your shelter if you go through
like a rough patch and like your
girlfriend kicks you out and you just
sort of like need some place to live by
the beach hope Henry's okay I've never
met somebody's hasn't heard check out
these tricks my cats can do I heard my
cats around here somewhere it's around
here it's around here somewhere you'll
you'll see her she'll make you sneeze
when you're a dog owner compared to a
cat owner it automatically sort of
endorses a more active lifestyle how do
you play with cats you just sit on the
ground the cat leaves for a while yeah
you're having social experiences but
it's only for like a couple moments at a
time the rest of the time you're either
dragging it around or picking up it's
[ __ ]
I will admit like there's something
gross about like having to take a dog
out and like looking at its butthole but
at the same time it's like nice it's but
neither of my dogs ever shouldn't house
I know for a fact your dog to my dogs
only when they're sick they [ __ ] are
loyal and they look at me and they say
Jen's great dens really dope if you want
somebody who loves you and will take
care of you we'll protect you and be
there when you have a child to raise it
and be part of the family
a cat can live for days without any
human interaction it's incredible it's
just like an awesome accessory to your
life you don't get any of the benefits
of actually learning how to take care of
something
yeah it sounds pretty cool you can't
just like leave them leave a ball for
your dog if you're just gonna go out and
like have a Vision Quest in Joshua Tree
I'm not saying like we endorse peyote
here but cats are the more peyote
friendly have you ever just started
petting a dog they're like the needy
friend who just once constant
reassurance am I pretty am i pretty am I
pretty
yes dog your pre you continue petting it
and then it's like do I just do this
forever when do you want me to stop have
you had enough and it's just like
looking up at you cats are soft and they
cuddle and then make this cats are
brought to hospitals because they have
healing powers they're giving to
patients and the purring helps people I
thought there were cats that were in
hospitals that like actually hovered
around people rather die yeah it was
pretty cool dogs are just like smelly
filthy [ __ ] Walker's are [ __ ] filthy
too because you know what they got their
shitty little paws on your table buy
your pad thai you move a couch and cats
like [ __ ] themselves yeah you can move a
couch around there's like fun
couches here now I'm just doing like
like myself and like you want Patton
ain't cool I'm here if not I'm out I'll
be like cuddly belly sometimes they
don't make aware of cat signs people
don't have traumatic experiences by
being scratched by a cat
no never like it draws a lot of [ __ ]
blood okay
I handle cats with two sweaters on and a
pair of [ __ ] mittens I don't play
ancient Egyptians worshiped cats as gods
they also kept uses slaves we're gonna
call that an even point dogs most of
them have been bred to not be good at
living anymore
Bulldogs those things like are hardly
functioning Bulldogs [ __ ] I just don't
really understand what about cats makes
it more sophisticated you find a lot of
rich people with cats like I don't the
Westminster Dog Show is like the bujji's
thing in the history of bougie things I
mean I will consider the Westminster Dog
Show it's like absolutely insane yeah
there's like a section where they're
like colobus dogs balls and the guys
like I never had a litter box for one
year that I lived in Tennessee and I
lived there 17 years people dropped off
dogs and cats oh wow what a great they
got our own a cat now because I'm a show
independent person just like living my
life and I'm ready for adventure cats
don't vomit yeah they do I have a gif of
it I go and I'd like to see my old cat
Simon and my parents got when I was
still in high school Pet is like furry
little belly which is so soft Jamie 90%
of the people who hate cats are allergic
to cats and therefore just have not hung
out with cats
the alergies cats mildly allergic there
you [ __ ] go my own opponent my
opponent okay all the animals vomit yes
dogs vomit more than cats I highly
disagree with that I drove past a dog
vomiting on my way to work today
ultimately you're gonna love murderers
and I'm gonna love independent little
beings that admittedly don't do a lot
but I kind of like that the lion that
tiger the Snow Leopard compare them to
the available dogs and it's clear that
cats are better than dogs that's it man
or woman's best friend they got your
back dogs aren't gonna throw you away
they're gonna look at you they're gonna
say hey I can find something within you
that's special and worth holding on to
and worth caring about all I can say is
like I think you're projecting a little
bit onto your shower your dog I also oh
I love cats
they love me [ __ ] adorable dogs are
always better will always be better you
know whose man's best friend man we're a
lot better at taking care of ourselves
and we can have a lot more fun with each
other wasn't too long ago that you and I
were friends
you don't have to pick up [ __ ] and like
get your leg bucked and whatever else
happens in Darla's but I don't know cuz
dogs are it's just so sad what's
happening over there oh yeah you don't
know the half